so as we all know affordable housing is
a crisis here in southern Nevada and
Clark County ranks
as a representative and a member of the
Appropriations Committee I fight every
day to bring housing dollars to Nevada
but you actually need Partners on the
ground who can put that money into the
ground and build projects and so to me
this project represents the promise of
being able to do that and start to make
a dent in our housing crisis here in
southern Nevada yeah there's uh
incredible demand like I said we rank at
the top of the list of cities and and
which families spend them you know one
over one-third of their income on rent
uh you know we know that we have so many
people waiting for affordable housing
system